there will be differences
in a deeply polarized country nearly
half of peruvians supporters of keiko
fujimori
are disappointed with the election
result pedro castillo won the presidency
with just
50.1 percent of the vote
on monday castillo issued a call for
unity
i ask that kiko fujimori not place
barriers in the way
so that we may move forward and make
this a government of all peruvians
nearing the finish line last week
fukimari supporters tried to reach the
presidential palace by force
they said to take over the government
and prevent a left-wing president
to take over fujimori has asked
supporters to protest peacefully
however she said castillo's proclamation
is illegitimate
and accused castillo's party of stealing
votes from her
oil today i swear i will not give up
i invite you to put up a real democratic
defense
peru needs all social and political
forces united
to stop communism defend free press and
democracy
pedro castillo will not only have to
face a strong opposition in congress but
also from party members
right before castillo takes over the
government the freight pedu party he
represents will meet
analysts say its members may demand that
castillo implements
radical left-swing policies highly
unpopular
among most peruvians
most peruvians say they are more afraid
of their economic situation
nearly one-third are now poor and the
pandemic has left
more than three million people without
jobs despite the dire conditions
some peruvians say it's time to put
political divisions aside
we wish him the best of success we all
have to work together
for a revolutionary change for the
well-being of everyone
without differences all as one
those who voted for castillo say they
are less concerned about him
implementing any sort of extremist
measures they just want to watch his
actions closely
and not give him a blank check mariana
sanchez lima peru